hi I'm max Saltonstall and today I'm
going to talk through some simple things
you can do to secure your workloads and
sensitive data in the cloud while still
keeping it private we're going to talk
about how shielded VMs and confidential
VMs can help you do this let's start
with creating a shielded VM in the
Google Cloud console shielded VMs our
virtual machine instances that are
hardened with a set of easily
configurable security features to ensure
that when your VM boots it's running a
verified boot loader and kernel using
shielded VMs helps protect workloads
from threats like remote attacks
privilege escalation and malicious
insiders and yes everything we do here
could also be done through G cloud and
the command line starting at compute
engine go to VM instances and then
create give it a name then go down to
boot disk and click change choose any
image they're all shielded by default
close that window with select at the
bottom and then go down to the tabs
labeled management security disks etc
and click security you can see the
default shielded VM settings let's
enable secure boot here for extra
protection and then click create to spin
it up turning on secure boot gives us
added protection from boot and kernel
level malware once it's ready click on
the new VM and click on stack driver
logging under logs on the detail page at
the logs page you can filter for just VM
integrity logs by clicking on the all
logs drop-down and choosing shielded
underscore VM underscore integrity now
you can see just the shielded VMFS for
this instance let's dig in further click
into the log for early boot report event
then expand the JSON payload then the
early boot report event inside that you
can confirm the VMS integrity state from
the early boot perspective from the line
showing policy evaluation past his true
early boot encompasses firmware and
other drivers loaded during the boot
process of the VM back to the logs list
open up the log that starts with boot
counter then expand JSON payload then
late boot report event shows you details
about the integrity of the rest of your
kernel drivers once again you can
confirm the boot integrity of the VM
from the line paulo
the evaluation past being true that
shows that the VM passed all eight boot
checks and is running what we expect it
to be running no shenanigans now head
into cloud shell to disable secure boot
so we can test this integrity check Oh
[Music]
first stop the VM with G cloud next
disable secure boot using G cloud update
now restart the VM
and you can see in the console that the
integrity verification has failed by
examining the same logs as before
finally make a new integrity baseline
with G cloud so you can compare future
measurements against the current state
pretend that you already triage this
failure and consider it acceptable with
this new baseline established go check
the integrity state of the shielded VM
again in stackdriver logging make sure
you click load newer logs to get the
latest results looking at the late boot
report event again we can see that the
policy evaluation past is true once
again showing that we have met our
integrity standards the ones we just
lowered of course finally time to look
at these metrics over time via
monitoring open up monitoring and head
to metrics Explorer under find resource
type and metric choose the resource GCE
VM instance and the metric early boot
validation
[Music]
then add a second metric late mood
validation we've got our graph though
it's going to make more sense as a
stacked bar graph looks great now you
can keep track of your integrity over
time with gorgeous colors when our
customers are ready to move their
workloads to the cloud one of the
biggest challenges is securely
processing sensitive data in the cloud
while keeping it private Google Cloud
offers solutions to securely bring
sensitive data to the cloud using
encryption to protect data in transit
for offline or online ingestion but when
we have to actually use the data it's
much tougher to keep it encrypted with
confidential computing now in beta
Google Cloud lets you take data security
a step further by encrypting data while
it's being processed in a Google Data
Center confidential computing
environments can now enable encrypted
data to be processed in memory without
exposing it to the rest of the system
and this can be done without the need to
make any changes in your workload or
code let's take a look at the product
but making a new confidential computing
VM which contains a shielded VM to
perform the computation inside compute
engine create a new VM instance enable
confidential computing service with a
checkbox note what changes are being
made to your VMs with this setting then
click enable you can run any workload
you want your VM is now much safer and
more secure with all the memory
encrypted so your data is safe in use
but what about instance templates and
groups you might ask well we've got you
covered the same confidential computing
option is available for instance
templates and you can either use one of
our pre-made images or your own custom
image that best fits your workload
[Music]
now my template defines a shielded
confidential VM setup and I can go to
instance groups to make a managed
instance group with that template beep
bop Boop we're done with a set of
instances auto-scaling for my needs
secured and ready to work
confidential computing environments can
now enable encrypted data to be
processed in memory without exposing it
to the rest of the system and this can
be done without the need to make any
changes in your applications thanks for
joining me today
enjoy shielded VMs and confidential
computing for your workloads on cloud
and check out the link below to get
started
[Music]